foreign
Rhode Island blocking a scene so it
looks like a bunch of NPCs are waiting
through a well-lit kiddie pool
if you're a superhero or not jump
scaring a bunch of soldiers with loaded
guns is never a great idea and will
always get you a sin how do they get the
formula
honestly we have no idea the fact that
we find out Stillwell honestly doesn't
have any clue that homelander has been
shipping compound V around the globe to
create super villains might be the most
unbelievable part of this episode the
fact that superheroes exist is literally
more believable than this plot point it
is a whole new world now
and there is only one company
that has the product
fight back how is there only one company
that manages superheroes I could buy
that VOD is the most successful company
but I'm not buying that they're the only
one
episode has time for this I hid this
under my floorboards right after daddy
left hiding things under floorboards
sounds like a cool fun thing kids do
sure but I've never met a floor without
a subfloor or a child Adept at removing
floorboards I thought I did what was
right thinking we'll accept that excuse
for this wallpaper you know the whole
reason the Navy discontinued their sea
mammal line clearance program
because it costs way too much to train
the Dolphins it's probably more accurate
to say that this was too expensive to
maintain all the support staff and
Equipment required for the program but
we all know that deep is an idiot so the
sin is that the Navy replaced the
dolphins with cheaper robots automating
perfectly good jobs no I'm seriously
leaving Jeff
Ohio
what are you looking at out there
Eastern meadowlarks it was either bird
watching or alcoholism so want it both
there's a clear reason for the existence
of Famous Grouse wild turkey and Old
Crow but then my grandchildren got
incinerated grandkids complicated
intimate hard to quantify the intro to
my online dating profile somehow makes
it into the episode when those knew the
front Perth has scrubbed and there's a
black vein with flowers and I'm probably
full of what in the jumpers acting like
a van full of flowers doesn't warn
caution on its own what I have allergies
and an insult to Robin's memory I think
I'm doing this for her it's very
satisfying to see Huey complete his
Heroes journey and remember who he was
before all this got started he's
standing up to Butcher and is no longer
letting him use Robin's memory as a tool
of manipulation so take one off for our
boy being all growns up then add one
back for this being a student has become
the teacher cliche the Deep shapes his
body to Rems Everybody Hurts because of
some sort of transformation theme but
all I can think about is him getting
shaving cream in his gills and it's
making me uncomfortable I was almost
arrested just for knowing you misreading
the situation you're definitely almost
lasered and now you want me to help your
Psycho Killer friends Huey doesn't
answer with
[Applause]
you have 30 seconds to get the hell out
of here setting an arbitrary ticking
clock I mean why
interrupting your arbitrary ticking
clock you saved me when did I ever save
you from blue balls falling out I mean
the bowling alley that's what I meant
hey
what the hell are you doing show plays
this like Nathan was just passing by
this train yard on the way to the
grocery store and just happened to see
his brother using this train not as
directed that was seen you back on that
compound V you bones fuse back together
overnight that is a good thing right she
has been very clear about the negative
side effects of compound V why is it
trying to speed past what sounds like a
breakthrough in medical science
sitting down by someone on a piano bench
without their explicit consent playing a
piano with gloves on Madeline
Mr Edgar waiting Eight Episodes to whip
out your Giancarlo Esposito start
thinking about the view from 82. and on
your way there talk to Kevin on seven
and be sure to dine on 29 and take a pee
on 43. thank you
this is the most premature celebration
to ever prematurely celebrate those
burnout eye sockets from later tonight
could see you now still will electricity
goes in glass comes out it's a hell of a
party trick do you ever um
use it for fun I think we all deserve a
little explanation about what this guy
is thinking because it sounds like he's
trying to get his rod lightninged on the
mood for what your bottomless casual
cruelty bottomless casual cruelty the
newest Trend you may have heard your
kids talking about is it getting kicked
in your bare balls or the hottest new
brunch item find out more at 11. as you
could bounce a quarter off of are there
asses that you can't bounce a quarter
off of to me that seems more likely to
be the exception
sweet boy I'm pretty sure there could be
an entire book based on this series
titled things to never say while having
sex
[Music]
they look prisoners inside the pillory
Barrel
and they kneeling their own excrement
until they got sepsis and died a detail
that for some reason the Medieval Times
dinner and tournament in Lyndhurst New
Jersey does not want you to tell the
patrons the only reason I even applied
was that I thought the establishment had
an appreciation for historical accuracy
it's just that
you carry so much and
the pain of losing a child to
miscarriages so Stillwell knew that
homelander visited vogelbomb and knew
that vogelbaum had told homelander about
the baby but didn't tell still will that
he told homelander the baby died a few
seconds after the birth because if
that's what this episode is trying to
tell us I do not believe you Juiced up
on his Newfound confidence yui mounts a
one-man rescue operation armed with
nothing but a retainer he didn't even
know if mother's milk and Frenchie were
together still alive or that he would
end up in the same place as them
man there's a during the retrieval of
the retainer where it looks like
Frenchie is holding onto Huey's tongue
and I have no idea what's going on or
why afterward Frenchie looks pissed that
Huey somehow didn't enjoy unwashed
fingers in his mouth
Frenchy's the only one that gets shot
despite them all standing out in the
open this may be slightly better than
Stormtrooper aim but it's equally
dependent on plot armor convenient wall
for cover is convenient almost like
someone designed this room with a
shootout in mind Huey straight up
murders this guy that was just doing his
job and who's most likely got a family
don't worry about that though I'm sorry
because it's funny that Huey's using a
gun also apologizing to people before
you murder them these faceless guards
who are shooting to kill a moment ago
will go all soft now and just try to
arrest them because that's exactly how
this should go down for our protagonists
no justice will be had for Brad what's
his name I've given this guy to make his
death more real to you face the wall
satisfied with just knocking this guy
out Starlight puts him up in the ceiling
I'm the one he wants
I'm not leaving you that's sweet but
this just tasks her with protecting you
as well as fighting a train it'd really
be better if he just left and other
things I've heard from my exes so the
question on the table is whether or not
a train would have to be running faster
than the speed of light to avoid these
blasts now I have my opinion and you
have yours and both of them are part of
the problem kill me
and my trigger finger goes soft I
wouldn't have expected such a normal
reaction from someone with a strange
nickname for their penis you are pretty
darn impressive I mean especially for
you know
one of you I gotta hand it to the show
for putting butcher Toe to Toe with
homelander without him immediately
getting lasered and having that somehow
make sense for the story that probably
would have been enough for a sin removal
but then the show pulls off a Twist
where Billy doesn't actually have the
leverage over homelander that he thought
he did and still he is somehow not
lasered and still it makes sense
ultimately Billy being alive has nothing
to do with some convenient
homelander is the same sadistic psycho
he always is and it all really comes
down to his up sense of humor
about everything this show is absolutely
stuck the landing on this final scene
and deserves multiple sins off so let's
give it one for every episode that got
us here
back to focal bomb
I managed
this show has suddenly grown a
conscience against scenes where body
part gets smooshed I guess but I want to
see the smudged body parts
[Music]
I'll find out this season whether or not
baby teddy survives so that's potential
baby murder which is definitely getting
you a sin I'm your father
we
are a family Cliffhangers
why don't you uh go have a smoke or
something okay I got
this oh and uh you guys
good job you're a hunter meaning you're
whatever the job you're doing today it
was either a bird watching or alcoholism
so
ooze and penicillin I mean why the hell
would I ever help you
because that's what Heroes do I'm a
superhero wanna make out why am
I sweating so much because you're
feeling it